à tous et bienvenue sur cheesecom FR
pour ce nouveau match le prochain League
entre les gnomes Norway et levitov chess
Wizard donc on a aujourd'hui des très
très bonnes affiches avec par exemple
ici avec les Blancs Costes champion du
monde contre Salem salé qui est le
numéro 1 des Arabes Unis donc quasiment
2700 euros donc ça marche très très
chaud vous allez voir beaucoup de
parties intéressantes avec plein de
joueurs hyper fort comme James going qui
est qui est un des des meilleurs joueurs
anglais on aura aussi Denis lazavik qui
a joué le championnat du monde de
blitzerapy et qui est d'ailleurs qui
était pas très très longtemps dans la
première table c'est un jeune joueur qui
a 16 ans et 2550 hello on aura aussi
pranave le joueur le joueur indien qui
est qui est très jeune aussi à peu près
15-16 ans 2550 avec ma médov bref
beaucoup de matchs très très intéressant
en tout cas j'espère que vous allez tous
bien sur le chat et qu'on va sur un bel
événement ensemble
donc cette partie on commence donc ça
c'était une petite à lapine avec E5 e4c5
C3 cavalier F6 E5 cavaliers 5 donc ça
c'est rien de très très surprenant
fougueux 5 food D7 et fouca donc ça je
ne connaissais pas et ici après 6 D4
prise qui avait laissé 6 petits rock
Caval B6
généralement on aime bien jouer dame 2
avec les Blancs
pour en fait
de dame 2 c'est de jouer en fait dame 4
et fonctionner plus tard pour me lancer
maps en H7
donc voilà prise prise
qu'est-ce qu'on peut voir ici peut-être
fou cette un coup standard ici on va
jouer 3 dans le 2 fous j'ai 5 je pense
avoir un développement comme ça
salut poignard comment vas-tu
tout seul pour l'instant mais ne
t'inquiète pas je vais être rejoint dans
quelques instants par un invité de luxe
que vous avez vu il y a pas très très
longtemps
dans un stream avec un avec Laurent
freissinet donc ce sera pas l'orange
aujourd'hui mais sera quelqu'un d'autre
et qui avait streamé une fois avec
Laurent
alors attendez
son compte je vais
je vais l'inviter sur discord pour quand
il arrive attendez parce qu'en fait
c'est un petit peu compliqué le match
qui aurait du moins s'il y a une heure
et au final il savait pas si l'annuler
ou pas parce que les problèmes en fait
avec cheescom le serveur tout ça et du
coup il voulait annuler puis finalement
ne pas annuler et au final ils ont fait
ça un petit peu à la dernière minute
donc on a tous été un petit peu surpris
si vous voulez et
donc voilà c'est pas Kevin non plus
salut charpentier c'est l'invisible
ombre et
je sais pas s'il veut que je l'appelle
de suite mon invité est-ce qu'il est
prêt
est-ce qu'il est prêt
parce que du coup pour venir la vérité
j'ai même pas eu le temps de mettre la
caméra des joueurs mais ça va venir
juste après pendant la ronde
pendant que
mon invité sera là il va prendre le
stream pendant que je mettrai les
caméras c'est pour ça que je l'ai pas
encore fait et là il est en train de
m'écrire
je crois qu'il sera là en quelques
instants alors cavaler cette roi du coup
logique on garde les pierres enfin plus
d'espace
faut prendre serait un peu bizarre je
pense donner la part de fou au blanc ça
serait vraiment quelque chose de
difficile
écouteurs du coup le son va pas être bon
si j'ai un invité alors je vais
commencer déjà par le par l'appeler mon
invité comme ça vous allez le découvrir
en même temps
alors je vais l'appeler
ça sonne bip bip
parce qu'il va vouloir me répondre
allô je crois que tu es là
tu m'entends bien ou quoi
ok salut alors là vous avez Nathan
Nathan qui est venu qui est venu stream
avec Laurent une fois je monte un peu le
son parce que je pense j'entends pas
très très bien chez moi
un petit peu loin
le son non je t'entends pas très très
haut mais dites moi dans le chat si vous
l'entendez bien ou pas bien vous
inquiétez pas je vais changer la scène
là je vais mettre la caméra on va tout
changer donc je passe en mode studio je
vais commencer par ça est-ce que c'est
mieux comme ça
ouais je trouve que c'est mieux ok
chez moi les caméras sont mais sont
mises donc je vais passer par là et on
te voit donc voilà Nathan salut à toi
j'espère que tu vas bien très bien merci
je vais te partager du coup
en off l'autre lien pour que tu puisses
voir mon écran en fait et puis après je
mettrai les caméras ça me prend 3
secondes parce que tout était prêt en
fait chez moi
le lien le fameux lien tu sais
alors
tout ça
et du coup c'est accepté je fais ça ça
et
hop hop hop
ok du coup nous on est bon notre côté
normalement
je vois bien les chiquer
salut à tous alors Nathan si tu veux
bien une petite seconde je vais juste
tout régler
ça va prendre deux minutes vraiment
normalement tout était prêt alors
on a des prises un petit peu
[Musique]
comme d'habitude j'ai envie de dire mais
c'est ça qui fait le Beaujeu finalement
c'est ça parce qu'en fait il y a eu des
problèmes avec avec l'interface
et du coup ils ont failli nous enfin ils
voulaient en fait annuler la ronde et là
échangé un petit peu l'horaire en fait
exactement donc c'était assez difficile
de prévoir combien de temps ça allait
prendre pour il est le problème du coup
ils ont décidé de mettre pour l'instant
une heure de retard et pour voir un peu
finalement ça c'est assez bien goupillé
ça a été finalement en 30 minutes
même en avance à la fin c'est ça
donc là on a une partie assez
intéressante entre Costet new qui est
Salem c'est c'est bien ouvert là ouais
c'était nalapine et attends j'ai pas vu
tout ce qui s'est passé
pour être assez
épicé c'est la position qui sont très
chaudes sont très chaudes les blancs on
arrive souvent à pas mal de d'attaques
donc partie intéressante en tout cas ça
c'est un bon client il aime bien les
positions hyper chaudes j'adore ça avec
un roman G6 il pouvait pas être mieux en
effet
alors je vais vous mettre la caméra de
côté news là si vous voulez en premier
avant de faire autre chose
et puis après je continue avec mon
réglage
alors H4 donc un coup assez thématique
finalement avec probablement la menace
de je veux quelque chose comme cavalier
G3 donc pour protéger le cavalier en G5
et
donc pouvoir finalement profiter du
clouage de la tour en F5 avec la dame en
C2 c'est ce qui est fait d'ailleurs
donc c'est assez chaud parce que là sur
tout reprend H4 cavalier prend F5 damage
de échec le roi doit partir en F1 et
probablement qu'avec les Noirs qu'avec
les blancs l'eau que c'est nuque à
calculer qu'avec le rang 2 ça suffisait
peut-être mais ça a l'air assez chaud
quand même
ouais alors attends
je vous mettrai les flèches tout ça dans
quelques instants je mets juste
prends tout ton temps tout ça
et du coup chez moi la première partie
là je peux vous mettre les cannes du
coup hop voilà donc la caméra sont mises
pour la première partie maintenant il
faut que je mette les autres en cachette
mais du coup là vous avez déjà les
caméras c'est cool
alors du coup
alors Jim be Bruck alors qui est Nathan
je travaille pour chasse.com du coup je
m'occupe de coordonnées les équipes
françaises et allemandes et
donc je vis je peux venir de temps en
temps sur un stream pour dire bonjour
Quand quand il y a un peu de place avec
tout notre gros poule de streamer donc
parce qu'on a quand même pas mal de gens
en ce moment on a tous très
régulièrement on a Kevin thérieux sans
compter évidemment Kevin Bordy Fab
Mathieu donc ça fait pas mal de monde
plus Sami qui est notre traducteur et
qui s'occupe de nos réseaux sociaux donc
l'équipe est assez large finalement et
sans oublier évidemment Laurent qui nous
a rejoint il y a peu de temps qui a
d'ailleurs poste toute la semaine
dernière bonjour Ruth
et donc voilà donc mon rôle finalement
c'est de faire en sorte que tout se
passe bien pour les équipes de contenu
françaises et allemandes
longtemps et pas longtemps ça fait
quasiment neuf mois quoi mais si bébé
exactement
ça fait pas beaucoup
et moi je joue un petit peu aussi alors
je suis bien moins fort que je touche ou
que Samy mais disons que je me
débrouille j'ai un bon 21 22 quoi tu as
été tu as été quasiment cassant à le
mettre fin à mon nom t'as pas quasiment
rentré je me trompe
comment dire en officier c'est pas en
virtuel du monter à 22h quelque chose
comme ça
OK
ça c'est pas si bien goupillé que ça
pour
saler qu'il y a du coup donner une
petite qualité et qui se retrouve avec
un ressentent bon finalement tous les
signaux sont au vert pour que c'était
nuque avec les Blancs donc avantage
matériel le roi plus en sécurité et
finalement des pièces mieux coordonnées
on n'a pas la jauge de l'ordinateur mais
j'imagine que l'ordinateur doit donner
un bon plus de ou plus 3 quand même si
ce n'est plus ici
on a eu des bugs de caméras hier et puis
mais c'est quoi ce que j'ai parlé avec
avec
vanessaie qui s'occupe de ça je lui ai
dit que oui avec le zoom etc elle m'a
dit oui je sais on va essayer de faire
de plus plus simple
parce que là c'est cauchemar là c'est un
cauchemar de ouf en fait pour vous
expliquer comment fonctionne le zoom je
sais pas si vous en avez déjà entendu
parler ici donc on a un zoom avec
plusieurs salles enfin c'est vraiment un
château il y a une espèce de salle
d'entrée puis après il y a une salle par
équipe et parfois il y a encore d'autres
salles supplémentaires on peut aller que
dans une salle à la fois donc bon déjà
pour capturer les images de l'équipe
c'est un petit peu compliqué donc il
faut que chacun des hausse des décoasts
partage son image à l'autre mais en plus
si on veut accéder à d'autres
informations ça devient vraiment très
compliqué
donc oui on est on serait assez enclin à
simplifier ça pour les prochains
événements
mais en tout cas on a les images et on
va pas s'en plaindre
ça marche bien
le lien youtube
beaucoup plus simple
[Musique]
je suis pas fan
je t'ai jamais zoom
alors qu'est-ce qui fait que la chaîne
chelsecom US n'a pas le même design et
semble carrément plus fluide que le
chescom fr alors tout simplement c'est
une question de production là on est
enfin il y a tout seul plus moi à côté
là qui qui commente un petit peu mais
finalement chesscom US ils ont une
production entière donc ceux qui
commentent n'ont rien à faire ils ont
rien à toucher regarde juste
éventuellement ils vont mettre des
flèches et ça s'arrête là et il y a
toute une équipe derrière qui qui
s'occupe de la réalisation de de changer
les images etc donc finalement c'est
vraiment une question de de production
globalement quoi
je vais vous mettre du coup une nouvelle
partie
jaune
c'est ça
allez je vous ai changer ça la partie
sous la changer aussi du coup il y a une
belle partie de costenioc lors de ce
premier match alors franchement les les
apparements sont assez intéressants
parce qu'il y a pas mal de jeunes très
forts on va voir après tu vois laservic
il faut que je change les noms aussi
j'ai pas changé non
vous avez lasavik qui qui
en fait a fait un championnat du monde
de partir rapide assez monstrueux en
fait
en termes de résultats c'était juste
monstrueux
[Musique]
c'est un très jeune joueur c'est un
biélorus qui qui a 16 ou 17 ans et qui
est en train d'éclore ils ont sur la
scène internationale c'est ça
et pour l'instant c'est assez chaud
quand même parce que finalement John
s'il a bien avancé c'est toujours mais
il y a des petites roues sur casse
blanche
ouais donc avec sa dame
comment est-ce qu'il pourrait essayer
d'avancer que
le cavalier des cinq bloque bien mais
finalement c'est plutôt les blancs qui
voudraient prendre le contrôle de la
colonne avec le retour en D2 mais c'est
pas si facile d'arriver à dégager ce
cavalier des cartes alors pourquoi pas
BK
pour enlever un des défenseurs du
cavalier des quatre
et
est-ce que sur c'est prendre B4 sur
quelque chose comme cavalier prend F4 ça
pourrait être salisé
prise qui va le prendre B4 avec sûrement
la tour en D4 qui
qui entre en jeu ça l'air très fort en
fait tout simplement bah il veut il veut
virer ce qu'avait là
un beau cavalent de 5 qui peut pas être
viré et il pense qu'il y a des ruptures
quand même qui est en fait tous les
tournois devant le cavalier et en fait
du coup il y a une rupture là une
rupture là et ce que si on arrive
vraiment à jouer contre ce cavalier ben
ça peut faire mal
mais franchement tu vois laservic 25,40
je pense tu regardes son vélo sans ne
l'oubli il doit avoir 150 points de plus
loin c'est pas un cadeau ça c'est clair
ouais mais tu vois ce qui est cool en
fait c'est que par rapport à la formule
bah en fait c'est le troisième de
l'équipe quoi ouais et du coup c'est
intéressant tu vois
d'avoir des joueurs qui sont sous
classés comme ça il y a aussi un Indien
dans l'équipe d'en face pranave prana il
est il est complètement monstrueux aussi
pranave et pareil 25 et quelques
ça doit être intéressant la partie de
près neuf quand même mes 9 mois on peut
changer si tu veux t'en mettre pas à
changer les noms à chaque fois sinon
c'est pour ça mais c'est vrai que ça a
l'air de s'éterniser un petit peu là
chez laservic enfin John going il est en
train de tanker il sait pas trop quoi
faire je pense
allez on va aller voir la partie
ok
c'est beaucoup plus technique comme
partie ouais plus technique 3 4 5 6 3 4
5 6 donc là c'est un temps de marron
gris et j'ai l'impression que ça c'est
pas mal passé pour les noirs
il y a une paire de plan mais il y a
quand même des cases tu vois la case B3
notamment un cas de 5 et des pions des
pions un petit peu à bloquer alors
généralement le pion à trois contre le
pion B4 contre le pion A4 c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle pour les blancs à cause
de la classe B3 mais aussi le pion C4
qui peut pas soutenir en fait 3
là j'aime beaucoup beaucoup les Noirs
c'est le maroczi je l'ai joué toute ma
vie aussi avec les noirs et ça c'est une
position qui est assez cool pour les
Noirs
c'est un grand spécialiste de toutes ces
positions de dragons
dragon et tecilian à clé noir
généralement donc moi je me suis à
l'époque quand je travaillais ça il y
avait toujours ma Médor quelque part
et nationale aussi oui oui mais c'est
pas la même
[Musique]
mais oui enfin en fait moi je veux pas
du tout la même que lui en fait c'est
pour ça que dans les références lui je
le soins est un massacre rapide tu sais
et moi je joue pas du tout ça mais ok ok
c'est comme ça d'ailleurs qui qu'il
avait remporté une des parties à la
finale de la baie un truc
la seule partie qui l'a remporté
finalement finale de bac up contre
Étienne Macron c'était justement une
amarozzi comme ça avec les Noirs
[Musique]
en direct
après j'avais mis un petit peu dans
l'ordre
pour que vous voyez un petit peu qui
sont nos joueurs donc avec les Noirs
c'est ma méthode
et avec
les Blancs c'est le petit
le petit renneuf que j'avais d'ailleurs
affronté
autant de Créon c'était quelques années
et il avait 2100 hello il avait été très
jeune et
[Musique]
et du coup on avait fait nul
j'avais répété trois fois la même
position sans faire exprès
et vraiment au bonheur de mon adversaire
qui était tout content de réclamer la
nul j'avais une position qui était
nettement nettement avantageuse et on se
joue aussi on a le Blitz
je l'ai battu aussi j'avais gagné
et à la fin du tournoi il est venu me
voir il voulait
tranquille quoi c'est le gamin il avait
il avait 9 ans
et 2150 2002 en tout cas il avait donc
pour repérer les clients ça c'est clair
mais très chaud quoi très chaud et du
coup son père était très très sympa on
avait bien bien sympathisé aussi et du
coup
très cool donc il était la même
génération un petit peu que que tous les
Pragues tout ça sauf qu'il est un peu
plus
jeune je crois
pas plus pas beaucoup plus mais il me
semble qu'il est plus jeune donc
pradavre donc pour te donner un petit
peu un ordre d'idée de son élo sur
cheescom il est 3000 à peu près ça va ça
marque pour un troisième échiquier c'est
intéressant tu vois
[Musique]
je viens de regarder la exactement le
même âge que la zavik du coup ah ok
ils sont sur leur 17 tous les deux quoi
on a le petit poussin de bois qui qui
demande s'il y a des vérifications des
joueurs disant que James Gohan a bien
changé
après ça fait un moment qu'on l'a pas vu
non mais en fait j'ai les noms mais si
vous voulez le nom il faut que je change
à chaque fois c'est un peu chiant
en fait voilà c'est c'est les template
qu'on m'a envoyé par rapport au stream
qu'il faudrait que je change à la main à
chaque fois que je change de partie et
bon
les plans c'est qui non
je vais vous le changer mais bon c'est
vrai que c'est à chaque fois
voilà c'est changer
mais du coup il faut tout le temps en
fait à chaque partie il faut que je
change les caméras et les noms
on nous demande cette partie à partir à
Jones alors non justement c'est
l'inverse là c'est prennent avec les
Blancs contre ma meuf c'est ça
finalement avec les blancs ils prennent
pour l'instant il arrive à tricoter un
peu à activer sa tour là on s'est vite
mais techniquement ça a l'air quand même
un petit peu compliqué c'est à dire je
sais pas quoi mettre sur ton comme
pseudo pour toi
tu peux mettre mon pseudo de chaises
comme si tu veux par exemple c'était à
wilkiliot comme ça
tout de suite sauf merci je me suis dit
si je mets ça
on va
[Musique]
changer comme ça direct comme ça au
moins on l'a
mais
ça sent comme bien mal embarqué là pour
les blancs
d'ailleurs il gagne il a eu à vendre
au niveau de ses ouvertures enfin je
veux dire juste les trucs c'est
enfin son dragon avec le noir je trouve
que c'est génial quoi
et James grown je vous mets la caméra en
même temps
alors la zavitch
j'arrive à laboratoire
un gros craquage peut-être
alors ça a fait nul et du coup non c'est
terminé là donc là du coup on a trois et
demi de monstrueuse
3 et demi pour pour les Beatles c'est
monstrueux franchement quand tu vois que
en fait costenio qui a battu Salem Saleh
ça c'est la grosse surprise du jour
et parce que après derrière c'est cam la
zavit on avait dit on en a parlé dans la
vie qui qui est capable de beaucoup de
fin de faire beaucoup de choses là David
qui a fait nul contre john's going don't
Gowin c'est c'est un des meilleurs
joueurs anglais qui a quasiment 2700
hello donc c'est quand même aussi une
grosse pointure
numéro 2 de l'équipe ma Médoc qui va
pranave bon j'ai envie de dire que c'est
une partie mais bon au niveau des vélos
c'est assez logique
et Sarana qui battage suivi ben c'est
aussi logique donc en fait aux deux
dernières tables chez les Wizards ils
ont fait la grosse surprise de faire un
et demi sur deux contre les deux plus
forts de l'équipe en face donc très très
intéressant en tout cas alors attends je
vais je vais pendant ce temps là si tu
veux préparer les caméras pour la partie
d'après pour pas être embêté du coup
trois et demi zéro et demi pour
l'instant je vous rappelle que le
premier arrivé à 8h30 va remporter ce
match
donc voilà alors je vais pendant ce
temps là pour mettre les trucs donc du
coup ça va faire quoi
je peux te dire les prochains matchs
en tout cas c'est vrai que bon on voit
que les Russes ont créé entre guillemets
la surprise sur les dernières échiquiers
mais en réalité ils partent quand même
je pense favori en tout cas sur le
papier c'est vrai que prana est un très
bon joueur et qui a des très bons
joueurs chez les gnomes mais les Russes
ont fait un très bon premier match et
pour l'instant il confirme bien
évidemment dans l'eau il y a aucun
client
et ça ça envoie du lourd parce que ma
médaff enfin il peut jouer contre un
très jeune mais d'oeuvre c'est
clairement pas le client du coup surtout
en blitz à chaque à chaque championnat
du monde de rapides c'est vraiment le
gars que tu as pas envie de jouer parce
qu'il a 2600 mais il vaut plus en blizzc
quoi
moi je me souviens je l'avais joué sur
le XS il m'avait adopté
après c'est pas c'est vraiment très très
fort quoi
on a vu la partie du costumes quoi
c'était la partie où il y a eu un fou
prend hs7 et justement elle avait
sacrifié une pièce au début le roi de
Salé est sorti au centre et finalement
elle a récupéré
pas mal de matériel et elle a gagné
du coup si tu veux retrouver la partie
de Costa new que tu peux la trouver
facilement sur le
regarder de toute façon on peut la
regarder c'est vrai qu'on a le temps je
vais juste terminer ça
et après
je profite pour dire bonjour à Claude
Mercier qui nous suit depuis YouTube
donc n'hésitez pas à nous suivre
également sur notre chaîne YouTube que
ce soit la chaîne chasse.com fr mais
aussi la chaîne chef 24h donc maintenant
que nous sommes une seule et même
compagnie
et n'hésitez pas à vous abonner surtout
que
71% des viewers regarde ça c'est très
très bien mais 60 secondes pour cent des
viewers ne sont pas abonnés c'est
dommage vous pourriez être averti de de
nos prochains streams de nos prochaines
vidéos etc juste en cliquant sur la
cloche et on vous abonnant donc
n'hésitez pas ça ne coûte rien et ça ne
fait que nous supporter
et vous pouvez également évidemment
aussi vous abonner à la chaîne de stouf
donc
d'ailleurs j'ai failli restreindre
aujourd'hui tu vois
moi ça va revenir les gars je sais que
ça fait un moment que j'ai pas stream
j'ai été très occupé sur un étang mais
j'arrive je reviens
là je pense que cette semaine ça va être
ça va être la bonne
allez
prochaine vidéo comment impatient de
voir ta prochaine vidéo
[Musique]
que je t'ai promis que j'allais
t'envoyer
j'attendais le j'attendais qu'on
m'envoie le
la miniature qui a été faite du coup
nickel donc du coup je te l'envoie dès
que dès que Stream est terminé je
l'avais en ligne de toute façon
alors hop et c'est bon du coup je suis
prêt pour la partie
et tes expériences passées
[Musique]
voilà c'est Yume qui qui s'occupe à me
faire mon toutes mes petites
[Musique]
miniatures etc sur Youtube et du coup du
coup ben j'avais besoin de de lui qui me
fasse la miniature il me l'a fait
aujourd'hui donc je vais pouvoir
l'insérer dans le tout c'est tout ce qui
manquait je fais ça je la publie donc
vous la verrez après vous avoir rien de
façon et puis c'est une panique j'ai
fait un interclub samedi j'ai joué un
jour à peu près à 2000 Hello
donc c'est une partie comme assez
déséquilibrée j'avais les blancs mais en
fait la partie elle est vraiment belle
et en fait juste pour vous utiliser un
petit peu ce qui s'est passé dans la
partie c'est que j'ai
complètement blender un coup et un
moment donné on a l'impression que je
suis complètement foutu
et en fait j'ai trouvé un sacrifice de
dame qui était sorti un peu de nulle
part et qui est juste hyper hyper jolie
quoi donc j'ai joué qu'une dame de moi
mais c'était un volontaire et en fait il
se trouve que après le après la prise de
la dame de mon adversaire et ben il est
complètement perdant parce que ces
pièces ne jouent pas et en fait du coup
c'est plutôt un circuit de dame si vous
voulez positionner c'est pas genre dame
prend quelque chose pour mater derrière
quoi c'est vraiment je donne la dame
parce que je pense que mes pièces sont
plus actives que des siennes et donc
j'ai gagné comme ça et en fait assez
propre j'ai gagné 5 c'est quoi après
avoir donné la dame mais c'était pas
tactique c'était vraiment donc très
belle partie en tout cas je les
commentaires sur ma chaîne youtube je la
mettrai en ligne juste après le stream
donc n'hésitez pas à vous abonner vous
êtes sur Youtube moi je suis tout échec
donc je trouve comme c'est écrit sur le
sur le stream et puis échec je pense que
c'est tous l'écrire
passion de voir la vidéo
du coup c'était
c'est la deuxième c'était ça donc là
vous voyez à l'écran vous avez Salem les
avis c'est l'appariement qui va arriver
juste après la petite pause là
alors donc c'était une une à lapine
ok donc tout ça alors
ça ça
un tour 1re surprise pour moi mais après
bon je suis pas parce que la pile mais
la Meuse c'était pour moi le coup
original fou des deux OK
en fait c'est position sont vraiment dur
pour les dents parce que
le jeu des blancs est très facile tu
vois on voit qu'un Caval 5 qui peut
arriver il y a un dommage 5 qui peut
arriver très très vite il y a un faut
prendre un chat qui peut aussi arriver
avec cavalier 5 en fait très très vite
je peux
je peux lancer la table et avoir plein
de choses donc du coup intéressant quoi
je me dis je l'avais je l'ai pas vu
alors qu'on était en stream mais
c'est en train de mettre ta caméra et ok
j'ai 5 tac d'un MC2
donc le roi qui va en G6 regardez bien
parce que si jamais j'allais mettre le
orange et 8 ben il y aurait eu dommage 5
qui fait
matinarable matin
pour laisser le roi s'échapper tout
simplement je mangeais la recette et là
sur je pense que déjà ça s'appelle pas
mal mais aussi c'est vrai que pour la
tour là a l'air d'être mal
instantanément
donc du coup c'est maintenant parade
donc souvent le roi part en G6 c'est un
peu le pari qu'on fait on sacrifie une
pièce pour ressortir le roi ici donc
dame C2
de deux cases et qu'on est à côté et ben
on peut le capturer si ça le retour de
jouer donc on prend F6 donc la fiche
forcée pour sortir de l'échec
qui avait le 4 3 G6 alors sur 7 il y
avait des problèmes du du Fou en V4
ouais c'est force qu'elle a fait ici
il y a juste un pion de plus c'est la
grosse attaque tout L5 ouais c'est un
peu plus c'est un roi de plus quoi
la tour qui va tomber c'est juste
trop trop dur cavaler F3
c'est l'attaque
c'est juste complètement perdu Dame des
deux dames G5 ouais bah écoute belle
belle partie de de Costa news
franchement alors que la partie on
commence on va pouvoir vous montrer un
peu ce qui se passe dans cette ronde de
la partie qui vont commencer à l'instant
donc on a déjà Jones Costa news qui ont
commencé à la partie peut-être devant
vous là Salem Laza Beach
qui va aussi commencer en général à voir
cette partie parce que Salem qui vient
de perdre sa partie qui va vouloir un
peu se refaire contre un lasavik ce qui
en veut qui donc encore une fois je
j'avais commenté avec avec Kevin
terrario ce championnat du monde de
thérapie de la David tu l'avais été
hyper impressionnant
2540 et l'eau il sortait de part et en
fait bah il a fait un super tournoi donc
vous avez vu que je suis un joueur qui a
3000 élans sur chaise comme un peu comme
pranave donc c'est deux joueurs dans de
très très bonnes recrues je pense qui
ont 2540 donc c'est la très bon joueur
mais sur internet ils sont peut-être
plus forts que les vrais 2500 et l'autre
tu vois
ça clique bien quoi
je crois alors que du coup
dessin qui était le coup d'hameçon
j'imagine que ça va être aussi un peu la
mobilité de toute façon
[Musique]
je pense que c'est assez standard assez
normal tout ça
tu vois moi je connaissais des positions
ou justement mais souvent la dame en C2
pour essayer de faire klayer ces trois
quatre ou si on nous prend un F4 de
faire je prends pour contrôler très bien
la case de sang mais du coup c'est vrai
que sur dams2 bah souvent il y a le fou
qui vient à 4 et après faire damsa comme
ça quand on fait cavalier C3 et ben on
attaquera le fou
je vais le montrer donc souvent
et que fou prend on prend et on veut que
c'est que le centre ici et en tout cas
intéressant c'est que si jamais
les blancs enfin les Noirs quand je vous
faut un café et ben du coup là on joue
Damien maintenant et plus tard je
pourrais jouer de Caval C3 avec 15 tempo
sur le fou pour plus tard je regarde
mais en fait on gagne un temps plus tard
avec cette roi au final
mais le foufan aller-retour en E4 + 6 du
coup finalement c'est les noirs qui
perdentes donc là je vous assure que les
Blancs n'ont pas envie de donner la
paire de fou
donc le four va bouger ça c'est sûr et
certain alors est-ce qu'on le met en G5
pour essayer de provoquer un
établissement
où est-ce que je le mets directement en
D2 je peux aussi manger en D600
parce qu'en fait ok la question c'est
qu'est-ce qui se passe au moment où
enfin admettons que le foot parce
quelque part le blanc il voudrait faire
4 a priori donc le cavalier il ira se
caler en B4 maintenant que les Blancs
ont fait à 4 il peut pas vraiment être
chassé
donc ouais la question c'est comment
est-ce qu'on continue après FC
donc ça c'est assez logique donc faut
prendre des 6 moi j'aimais pas trop
parce que vous voyez ce fou de case noir
bon il est là mais là a priori il tape
quand même sur sur du béton donc on n'a
pas trop envie d'échanger on se dit plus
tard si on arrivait à jouer au 4 5 par
an sur votre sympa mais je pense pas que
ce soit bien d'échanger les fous avec
les Blancs j'ai quand même des belles
diagonales avec mon beau fou
donc il y a Camus F6 puis F5 pour
attaquer donc sans que ça a l'air pas
mal en terme de toi c'est assez offensif
mais de l'autre côté c'est vrai que la
case de 5 et le pion aussi sont devenus
un peu faibles alors je sais pas si ça
ça contrôle le 4 ça a du sens en tout
cas à contre le 4 on peut imaginer que
sur cavalier C3 peut-être un coup comme
cavalier F6 alors je sais pas lequel
mais par exemple
pour faire fou et 4
en tout cas avec le noir il faut se
battre pour les cases blanches ça c'est
clair moi je vais bien pour vraiment
vraiment lutter pour la caisse de 4 quoi
il veut juste mater tout simplement mais
en fait c'est vrai pourquoi pourquoi
échanger c'est vrai qu'on est pas pressé
de le faire
donc oui c'est pas une menace 4 parce
que du coup ça perdrait un pion avec
cavalier français 3 celui de la prise en
E4 plutôt manger du fou pour pas casser
la structure
et du coup dans mes 8 ben c'est très
bien dommage 5 et F6 et on va voir un
peu ce qui se passe quoi
donc bonjour 67 très bon choix de
département je vois
un bar
ça fait un peu penser aux positions de
hollandaise avec le pion F5 puis ramener
les pièces petit à petit
souvent le pion noir est aussi en D5
très souvent et se fout souvent c'est
une mauvaise pièce en C8 donc là c'est
une version assez intéressante avec au
final le fou qui va s'activer par là
peut-être un jour échangé
intéressant
en tout cas c'est un tendance à
dynamique ça fait réfléchir Salem
et donc on va ensemble comment comment
ça représente en tout cas là David qui
est passé quasiment sous la caméra
il se cache il se cache
et une partie en tout cas assez
intéressante
ici
mais je pense je pense honnêtement là
que Salem il commence à avoir une petite
poubelle parce que ces pièces sont pas
très bien coordonnées il y a pas
vraiment de levier qui puisse faire et
alors que le plan des noirs est plus ou
moins tracé quoi en tout cas c'est
l'arrière plus facile à jouer est-ce que
tu veux qu'on change du coup qu'on aille
voir une autre partie très bien tu vas
aller voir quoi alors on a un James
costumieu qu'on a Savannah prana samedi
je te prépare je te prépare tout ça donc
saranas donc c'est le l'échiquier 1 des
de l'équipe russe et pranaf c'est
l'échiquier 3 de l'équipe
mais comme on dit ça après 9 c'est un
jeune joueur indien de 16 ans donc très
dangereux qui avance à incliné face à
Mamie d'oeuf mais qui en fait peut
battre n'importe qui à n'importe quel
moment c'est un peu pile ou face quoi
c'est ça alors vous avez
les caméras qui sont apparues
sauf que j'ai pas cliquer sur la partie
ok 6 6 bah écoute moi j'aime bien les
blancs ici on a pas envie qu'il y a un
E5 qui va arriver peut-être un jour pour
ouvrir ce food case blanche là il y a
une paire de fou qui tape comme sur le
roi c'est c'est assez puissant en fait
les noirs des quatre mais bon pour
avancer de deux cases en diagonale il
faut 4 coups avec un cavalier c'est
compliqué pendant ce temps là moi j'ai
des choses à faire
quand on est arrivé là je peux je veux
rapidement je passais je vais faire
automatique avec tscom
la prise
de fou des blancs du coup
ça permet d'avoir une belle structure
pour les noirs
avec un pion en C4 qui est isolé mais la
paire de fou elle est case noir qui
s'ouvre donc
si les blancs arrivent parce qu'en fait
les blancs on a peur de fou donc qui va
l'ouvrir et les Noirs ils sont très
contents d'arriver à bloquer ils ont été
très contents d'arriver à aller jusqu'en
E4 avec le pion pour faire si les blancs
arrivent à prendre et à tout ouvrir d'un
coup comme là avec le fou B2 qui rayonne
à tout moment les 5 qui ouvrira le foot
casse blanche bah ça peut se compliquer
quoi
est-ce que tu penses qu'on peut quand
même réussir il y a même F4 qui peut
arriver en fait
si dur de trouver un mauvais plan quoi
parce que là je pensais à peut-être même
jouer à la place de l'entendais oui je
pense ça je vais quand même les 17 pour
faire ce plan jusque là en fait j'arrive
j'arrive
trop vite quoi
et du coup c'est pas simple mais il a
joué il a joué 5
va venir en T7 ou en
e84 juste après du coup ce qui va se
passer et en plus j'ai pas dû j'ai pas
de F5 avec les Noirs je crois
parce que je mets le cavalier j'ai que
deux cases ça c'est clair
[Musique]
on peut avoir des thèmes sur le sur des
avec des tours prend des trop ou des
choses comme ça mais je pense pas que ce
soit
est-ce que du coup il veut sur F4 est-ce
qu'il voudrait essayer de faire G6 et
qu'elle allait G7 mais il a peut-être
pas le temps en fait
pas très clair F4 G6
un salaire horrible mais
trop beaucoup trop dur
ça marche pas non
est-ce que du coup F4 F5 e prend genre
un espèce de cavalier prend et sur F5 un
dame D7 ou quelque chose comme ça pour
se retourner sur le foot des trois
mais tout va bien paraît danger
je sais pas si tu veux mettre quelques
flèches voilà
[Musique]
et du coup sur epran cavalier
et l'idée c'est que F5 on pourrait faire
Dame des 7 mais je pense que
pourra bien doit être dangereux quoi que
ça a l'air peut-être de tenir je sais
pas
en tout cas ça pourrait être une façon
d'essayer de résister
Adam G6 peut-être en défense
ça a l'air pas mal quand même c'est sûr
il prend son temps
[Musique]
à Serrana c'est un jeu assez tactique
mais enfin à la fois tactique et
technique c'est à dire qu'il va souvent
prendre son temps et il va être très
fort quand il le reste quelques secondes
mais ouais c'est pas le genre qui va
balancer une attaque extrêmement
rapidement s'il est pas à 100% sûr c'est
un peu
il a raison il faut qu'il faut qu'il
ouvre sans prise à C4 peut-être et c'est
trois et il va essayer de renverser un
petit peu le genou noir c'est peut-être
pour ça son idée au final de gb5
un peu curieux quand même tout à l'heure
en tout cas
mais c'est vrai que même là tu vois même
je sais pas laisser prendre ici il faut
prendre échanger les pièces au final ça
peut réveiller mon foot 15 mois j'ai
vraiment du mal à cette position pour le
j'aime pas du tout ou alors il veut
faire B4 essayer d'ouvrir la colonne
bain je sais pas mais il faut essayer de
faire quelque chose avec avec
l'impression que tu bouges plus c'est
vrai que c'est pas très drôle et moi je
vais passer par là non je pense qu'il
faut tout échanger en fait il faut
essayer de tu vois le cavalu qui peut
venir aussi après hein c'est pas non
plus
vite se retourner s'il y a un peu trop
de pièces qui se font cavalier bon si ce
sera là pour le même de mauvaise
décision ça peut se retourner ce que tu
veux aller voir un petit peu continue
[Musique]
elle vient de battre
donc position compliquée
il y a tension à diagonale ici les
blancs plus compact j'ai l'impression
avec des pièces Cannes un peu plus mieux
placées
la menace c'est quoi là
c'est direct avec
la menace la tour elle a pas la case en
C8 à cause du Fou
quelques problèmes techniques là pour
pour noir dans la pose
il y a eu prise en Cl4 ça intermédiaire
il veut chasser la dame pas beaucoup de
cases pour cette
je prends là
après je pourrais manger de la
directement ça c'est bien
mais tu vois ça permet d'attaquer enfin
de gagner la part de fou quelqu'un m'a
appris qu'à valider 5 je me place
on en fait quoi après on le remet en C5
d'en prendre
ces quatre moi j'ai la paire de fou et
après voir j'ai quand même des fois du
foot et 6 aussi une bonne tête pour les
blancs quand même oui
mais avoir avoir ça reste du bled il
reste quatre minutes 30 pour les blancs
contre 2 minutes pour les noirs
et attention quand c'est lui qu'il faut
pas du tout
sous-estimer Elven bad quand même le
numéro 1 de l'équipe d'en face 2700 et
l'eau ça allait après ça se trouve ça se
trouve Gohan s'il a tellement peur qu'il
va faire quel est le B5 quel est le SS7
qui a les B5 j'y crois pas du tout
j'y crois pas du tout en plus c'est un
joueur qui qui joue généralement quand
même Jones c'est un genre agressif
d'ailleurs moi j'ai kiffé son DVD sur le
stand-diène
c'est de la fait des vidéos
un livre des formations en ligne c'est
vraiment la référence bah tu sais que
moi j'avais une ligne qui me dérangeait
sur la serviette
sur mon répertoire et chaque fois que la
joue avec les Noirs j'avais toujours
plein de problèmes et je me suis dit bon
allez on va le donner une dernière
chance en gardant le
de john's going et du coup bah écoute je
continue à la jouer du coup parce que je
trouve que ce qui propose c'est
intéressant
et du coup maintenant bon j'ai toujours
compliqué la 5G
[Musique]
ça et ça va ça joue mais à un moment
donné j'avais envie même d'arrêter
tellement c'était difficile il y avait
des variantes qui me posent des
problèmes
je crois que c'est difficile de faire
une meilleure pub pour le Chessy bird
going du coup sur
après
souvent en fait les les vidéos de chess
Idol souvent ça sont quand même adaptés
à des joueurs qui ont déjà un gros
niveau en tout cas ce que je remarque
dans plein de vidéos moi j'avais vu les
sauts etc
[Musique]
qui sont quand même entre guillemets
accessible mais ça dépend jusqu'où à
chaque fois à quel point s'arrête et ce
qu'on s'arrête à la fin de ce qui nous
donne dans le tube ou est-ce que après
on pousse un peu les variantes aussi ça
change pas mal de choses
après après lui lui pousse quand même
mais
bon moi j'ai pas le jusqu'au bout en
fait ok
parce qu'en fait je m'en fous
très bonne raison en fait la raison
vraiment c'est que si tu veux
si tu veux tout simplement
tu es en t'as des positions ou tu sais
que c'est qu'il y a plein de jeux tu
sais que c'est compliqué etc et en fait
lui et Ben et ben il va il va vraiment
au bout du bout du bout du bout et bon
moi j'aime pas trop le Parker je sais
qu'une position bah je suis mieux on
joue quoi voilà et bon après je te la
vérité ouais mais il y a plein de lignes
qui servent à rien en plus
très loin il y a des pièges de tout mais
en fait en vrai ça arrive pas donc en
fait je me prends pas trop la tête moi
c'est juste pour avoir les idées
générales qui m'intéressait
et du coup je te fais ce que tu
recommanderais les stands à des joueurs
débutants ou à quel type de jeu est-ce
que tu recommanderais les stands
en fait ça dépend quel niveau tu joues
mais j'ai fait une DVD j'ai fait un une
vidéo par dessus sur Youtube d'ailleurs
qui est destiné aux joueurs
semi débutant on va dire
oui de en fait je suis pas rentré dans
les variantes profondément j'ai surtout
fait des des idées les plans et un truc
simple pour savoir où vous allez etc
donc je la recommanderais je la
recommande pas besoin d'être casse pas
offre pour tuer là c'est indienne
mais après après voilà plus on progresse
plus on peut rentrer dans le vif du
sujet on peut aller loin et voir et voir
votre truc
de ressources et enfin à tous les
niveaux on peut on peut arriver à monter
une attaque avec les Noirs comme avec
les Blancs d'ailleurs c'est ça
mais après voilà ce qui est important
c'est quand vous apprenez les ouvertures
il faut pas apprendre par cœur il faut
pas aller sur
j'ai appris ça par cœur c'est bon je
connais ça c'est contre-productif ou
c'est chaud non ça pique
donc ça c'est contre-productif en fait
ce qui ce qui est important c'est que
vous compreniez ce que vous faites
si vous comprenez ce que vous faites
mais qu'en plus vous connaissez les
coups
mais ne vous êtes pas droit de jouer un
coup dans une ouverture sans comprendre
pourquoi vous le secouer en fait parce
que ça c'est très mauvais
il a mangé ici il a pas et là il a
laissé la tour en prise
comment mater son adversaire
elle est imparable ça a l'air perdu il
faut contrôlage 7 et plus je contrôle le
math
il y a 10 secondes elle est pas contente
elle a mangé des deux
ok parce que du coup faudrait faire quoi
sur
[Musique]
du coup pour donner une case dans H7
mais du coup peut-être
du coup
pour pouvoir faire cavalier F6 sur H7
pour finir il faut c'est ça
il faut
[Musique]
au choix grosse grosse partie de de
Jones est-ce que tu veux aller voir du
coup qui tu vas aller voir les dis-moi
on n'est pas encore allé le voir allez
même EDF du coup je mets les caméras
pendant ce temps là
donc
une joueuse géorgienne quel type de
Grand Maître et bah c'est pas si clair
cette position là parce que finalement
le pion A5 des des blancs arrivent à
attirer les deux tours sur la colonne A
et les rendre un peu passive mais
finalement les Noirs ont quand même de
quoi faire valoir
leur chance donc voilà un pion E5 en
pion central un opus en C6 donc par
exemple si les si les Noirs venaient à
jouer quelque chose comme foot D4 pour
incroyable et que le foot des cartes et
le 5 se protège mutuellement ça pourrait
être intéressant pourquoi pas pour
justement pousser le pion de après faire
c'est simple c'est 4 etc donc les blancs
doubles sur la colonne B et
pourrait menacer éventuellement des des
petites choses comme des tourbes B8 pour
contrôler la dernière rangée et
finalement essayer d'éliminer chaque
tour qui bloque ce Piona parce que c'est
ce que veulent faire les blancs ils
veulent soit arriver à pousser le pion à
Adam soit justement entre avec leur tour
sur la 7e ou sur la 8e et les Nord
pourront difficilement contrer les deux
en tout cas belle pression des blancs
c'est vraiment un joueur très complet et
c'est un joueur qui qui généralement
pose beaucoup de problèmes au niveau on
le voit souvent dans les premières
tables d'un championnat du monde etc
c'est un joueur qui est très comment on
dit
[Musique]
je sais pas comment l'expliquer
différemment des gaffes et il sert les
dents quoi très efficace quoi c'est un
genre très efficace
et donc 26 50 hyper solide tu as tombé 6
la prof qui lui fait que le fou puisse
plus
ne puisse plus bouger
donc il veut changer des pièces
un prise prise dame B7 alors intéressant
c'est la partie tour à 7 je pense qu'on
va avoir dame B8 peut-être est-ce que
final elle est si bien que ça parce que
dès qu'on arrive à faire ces trois bah
c'est plus dur de protéger le pion là
bah ouais genre ça ça
et en fait bah écoute
on peut signer l'ami on peut signer la
feuille dame à 8 a été joué
les dames ça force les chances
et du coup
bon je suis pas obligé de manger
maintenant
il y a eu prises quand même et là il y a
7 ans qu'elle a menace
j'ai envie de dire
alors que là ça Beach a battu Salem
alors ça va faire nul mais en tout cas
ma médaff encore une fois il va tient
souvent je te changer pour aller une
partie un peu plus
chez ma MEDA c'était juste ça que je
voulais dire ah ouais
une belle position de foot couleur
opposé
et donc les foutres que le reposer ça va
souvent la réputation de faire nulle
mais quand on est en finale mais dès
qu'il y a de l'attaque souvent c'est le
camp qui attaque en premier qui a les
meilleures chances de gains et on voit
que la tour angélique bah enfin les
pièces noires sont un peu recrovis quoi
les blancs essayent de trouver un chemin
là
c'est pas si facile parce que la tour
peut pas quitter la deuxième rangée pour
l'instant sinon la dame prendrait le
pion en F2
pour D8
ouais c'est fini
il s'en foutait en fait c'est gagner
mais ça c'est ma tente de coup
et
Sarana qui alors du coup c'est à la
place de jouer
du jeu d'un point à trois si on restait
comme ça c'est pas simple à gagner parce
que après il faut 5
en fait qu'est-ce que je fais ouais
qu'est-ce que je fais faut que je garde
depuis un F2 en l'air et si il joue
c'est pas simple avec mon roi de la
défendre depuis
H4 je sais pas si ça apporte grand-chose
madame des fois en fait pour David
c'est pour ça c'est quand le fond en F4
en fait que ça défend plus
du coup
pour empêcher la tour de venir
du coup c'est pas si facile de passer
mais du coup les pièces noires sont
évidemment très passives et il y a rien
en fait non
elle bouge pas c'est tout bouge la dame
admettons
je sais pas encore comment parce que
foulager 5 mais ça a l'air quand même de
puer un max trash4 juste et je pouvais
faire qui va arriver ça a l'air d'être
moche
et peut-être même ça d'ailleurs sinon on
peut on va essayer de casser d'envoyer
un H4 G4 etc et ça ça va vraiment
ok ok un peu compliqué bon en tout cas
opposé c'est l'attaque avant tout donc
[Musique]
c'est facile
je vais vous remettre
les joueurs
éventuellement regarder comment ça s'est
quel était le dénouement entre nous
et du coup on voit que John ça a gagné
finalement
il a converti son avantage
ça fait nul alors pour vous montrer ça
le changer de
changer de bord
même au dessus là on va les scores ça
mangerait pas besoin de tout changer
donc James
[Musique]
et du coup il est fou et F4
numéro 1 c'est difficile et ça reste
encore plus difficile maintenant qui va
jouer les premiers rénaux quoi
après c'est un joueur qui aime beaucoup
attaquer donc il est capable de tout
gs5 G4 pour empêcher la position de
sourire
c'est c'est un peu bizarre tout ça
avec les Blancs quand même
ce qui est solide pour les noirs
sur la 6e c'est pas si facile de passer
avec les blancs les noirs contre les
toutes les cas sur la 5e rangée
ça ira 5 il va prendre H6 quand il veut
passer de l'autre côté et chaque
j'ai pris la peau de banane
qui
défend le cavalier mais en plus menace
une découverte pour manger la Tour
Blanche ça a été raté et là c'est
complètement perdu effectivement
du coup ça fait 6 2 pour pour les
buteurs alors 6-2 au bout de deux matchs
on attend on va peut-être insister à une
quasi première avec je sais que cela a
8h30 avant la quatrième partie et ben le
match s'arrête
une fois la semaine mais ouais après
c'est ton jamais avec comme ça la
remontada va être compliqué mais faut
pas vendre la peau de l'eau avant de
l'avoir tué ah ouais mais on a eu on a
vu le cahier avec un match un match de
malus carracène tu sais qui était enfin
il menait complètement
et au final à la fin ils sont tous faire
tourner quoi
alors attends je vais mettre les caméras
en même temps la médof
je crois que c'est lui qui est en bas
[Musique]
il aura les blancs qui va rester là
il va je compte ça les exactement ouais
on va voir Savannah contre gioven Jones
on va voir que je tenus entrepreneur et
là sa vie contre Nino Bastia juillet
là je les règle tu sais je les mets en
haut et en bas là
j'ai quand même
donc dans le chat dites-nous s'il y a un
match que vous voulez en particulier
suivre
mais a priori je pense que on va
probablement soit suivre le match de
Savannah contre gioven Jones soit ma
médoff contre salé
ça c'est clair
alors attends
c'est parfait
le dernier ça va être
sans blanc
contre la zavitch
et donc le programme de la semaine c'est
demain donc il y a l'équipe Blitz donc
de Blitz Stream qui joue à 16h30 entre
les Shanghai Tigers donc une équipe
chinoise notamment portée par Wailly et
donc ça ce sera sur la chaîne de Kevin
donc sur Blitz stream à 16h30 et après
on enchaîne à 19h donc sur la chaîne
chaise comme FR avec Saint-Louis menait
pas Fabiano Carona qui sera premier
échiquet contre la team mgd1 donc
finalement la team indienne justement
qui qui a perdu la semaine dernière
contre l'équipe de Blitz donc le match
Saint-Louis contre l'équipe indienne à
19h sur la chaîne demain
et vendredi en suivra l'équipe des
Gotham Knights donc mené par Hikaru
contre les California unicorns de Sam
chankland un très fort grand maître
américain et ce sera aussi à 19h donc
sur la chaîne chasse come fr donc
finalement demain et vendredi les deux
matchs seront à 19h
alors donc on les matchs n'ont pas
encore commencé j'imagine comment
moi je suis prêt là moi j'ai mis salam à
Médoc après on pourra tourner
toute façon
tu peux éventuellement dupliquer la
scène et mettre le deuxième match comme
tu préfères
du travail après mais comme tu veux
Sarana Jones ça me fait plus rêver que
ma médaille
c'est franchement les deux matchs se
valent
et à chaque fois ça c'est intéressant
parce qu'on a des styles bien opposés
du hobsc qui est plutôt un joueur
d'attaque et ça ramena plutôt un joueur
technique et pareil même mes doivent
plutôt un joueur technique contre ça
allait plutôt un joueur d'attaque et
bizarrement ça fait un peu école
soviétique contre soit les Anglais soit
salé je sais pas de quel pays vient
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
ouais les deux rues sont les blancs en
fait les deux rues mais d'ailleurs je
dis ça mais je crois que sur le drapeau
ukrainien maintenant
mais j'ai vu il y a pas longtemps ou
alors c'est un peut-être un autre joueur
azerbagiana qui jouait pour le drapeau
ukrainien je sais plus non mais oui ça
doit être normalement
je sais pas pourquoi il y avait un
drapeau ukrainien qui traînait pour un
des joueurs
pour un des joueurs
Algérie
il est jeune en fait enfin il est pas il
est pas très beau
je vais pas faire le mec mais tu as que
4 ans d'écart avec ma méthode
moi non
[Rires]
j'avoue que c'est ouf
j'avoue que c'est ouf bon par contre je
préfère
[Musique]
ouais ouais c'est la coupe de cheveux
qui fait ça
dans le château
[Musique]
qui me dit qu'on a dépassé les 1000
pardon les 100 messages dans le dans le
Turc
j'attends avec impatience les 200 donc
n'hésitez pas à participer à nous donner
votre avis et
sans oublier suivez-nous sur Youtube
j'ai un peu me répéter mais suivez-nous
sur Youtube 71% des des viewers sont pas
abonnés à la chaîne donc faites partie
de cette tiréductible part de 29% qui
qui sont abonnés
un petit message en privé sur twitch
alors moi sache que je n'ai rien fait
mais je vais te le je vais te l'envoyer
sur discord
parce que
voilà je te fais je suis
c'était pas un message pour moi je crois
mais merci beaucoup en tout cas pour ton
message faites Fox
ok merci de nous avoir fait part de ça
c'est un bon point
[Musique]
donc c'est parti qui ont pas commencé
encore donc après ça va te la rendre 3
du coup normalement
si on a on a la ronde un qui vient de
démarrer à l'instant enfin pas encore
les parties mais on va avoir en tout cas
la partie donc ma médoff contre Salem
salé
qui commence à l'instant donc une
Espagnole donc là il y a plus que deux
et demi pour les vitov
pour gagner ce match
et
[Musique]
donc là ils peuvent les mettre ces
petits points vous avez un parement qui
sont affichés en dessous de nos caméras
donc
on peut saler ou sucré
plutôt sucré moi
plutôt salé
on passe un temps il faut pas qu'on
aille au resto ensemble
[Rires]
qui est bon secondaire dans l'espagnol
c'est d'ailleurs ma préparation
contre le célèbre robinsai on s'était
joué en équipe
c'était où c'était
[Musique]
Toulouse à Toulouse contre ces jeux je
crois et j'avais les noirs et je pensais
jouer contre robinside non c'était à
Toulouse c'était loin très loin
je crois bien que c'est Toulouse
c'est pas à Cannes
et
tout ça fait plus d'une heure de voiture
donc c'était vraiment loin c'était plus
vers chez lui que vers chez moi et je
savais que ça me jouait avec Dame 2 à
l'époque comme ça c'est pas grand chose
j'ai préparé dame
j'ai une question je trouve pourquoi
est-ce que tu utilises le passé
c'était comme ma phrase ah oui pas grand
chose parce que je raconte une histoire
qui s'est passé il y a dans le passé
mais c'est vrai que c'est une histoire
qui qui pourrait être encore actuelle
quoi mais
[Musique]
du coup j'avais préparé ça et ça
m'imaginer à une certaine
espagnol d'échange finalement
on a fait nul c'est une partie
intéressante je pense
un moment donné je prends cette mieux
mais je rate un coup et
aussi parce que ça aurait pu mettre
dedans
pour faire un vis-à-vis avec la dame sur
D8 mais les blancs apparemment vous
pouvez pas faire des quatre très
rapidement il doit y avoir probablement
un petit problème qui temporise avec des
trois pour sûrement pousser plus tard
parce que c'est pourquoi
j'en sais rien mais
alors donc ça c'est les positions en
fait on la transposée à un petit peu
dans une
position assez standard tu vois il y a
pas de pollution comme ça
bon dans l'espagnol mais aussi dans dans
la Sicilienne tu sais on peut transposer
dans une
style de position moi je suis souvent ça
sans jouer espagnol tu vois par exemple
sauf que c'est un peu différent
finalement comme on arrive à jeter 4 on
a plus de malade qu'avec les blancs
et en fait il faut que tu partes tout en
abandonnant en fait le cavalier parce
que j'ai pas de cases partout je suis
mangé et quand je bouge tu manges mon
cavalier donc est-ce que là il y a une
pointe après il peut y avoir cavalier
prend un 4 pour prendre en B6 du coup
c'est sûrement ce qu'il a vu parce que
sinon dans ça a l'air bien
parce que là je garde mes cases tu vois
une bonne tête ouais c'est ça et
j'ai aussi cavaler prendre comme tu le
disais un sa mais ça m'a l'air un peu
moins un peu
plus enfermé j'ai pas la casse des seins
il y a une une réelle question à se
poser ici
savoir si on joue vraiment ou pas
qu'elle va les prendre au 4
et si on fait pas qu'elle prend quatre
on fait quoi du coup ce qu'on fait de
dessin
après
qu'est-ce qu'on joue alors là il y a
plusieurs idées intéressantes donc je
vais vous donner une bon dommage
quelque chose que je voulais
juste pour vous donner une indication un
truc que je peux voir qui est
intéressant en terme de structure de
pions et de je positionne là la menace
D4 est une idée intéressante alors
pourquoi alors je vais juste jouer un
coup pour pour vous montrer bon
l'idée en fait c'est que si les Noirs
mangent bon tout simplement en fait là
je vais réussir à prendre de l'espace
etc si les blancs touchent rien ils se
disent moi j'attends et ben là l'idée
c'est de faire des Français 3 B prend
celui de B4 qui a un coup ici hyper
intéressant pour en fait venir gagner la
case des cadres
qui maintenant nous permet de gagner la
case et du coup jouer avec ce pion
arrière plus tard etc etc
donc ça c'est des idées qu'on doit avoir
aussi en tête quand on veut sa position
comment est-ce qu'il veut jouer
[Musique]
en tout cas avec les Noirs il faut juste
faire attention à pas libérer le foot
casse blanche probablement
mais en vrai même un écran
pas tellement que ça
avec le foot sorti
de structure et moi j'adore la fille
d'or
mais du coup ça c'est intéressant en
terme de structure j'aime bien tu vois
donc là en fait ce pion en croit des
trois ça me fait absolument pas peur ma
vie avec ça
mais du coup avoir les pièces actives
les blancs enfin les Noirs vont un
avantage d'espace mais les blancs
contrôlent toute la quatrième orangée et
à tout moment où les Noirs les Blancs en
profiteront les Noirs vont être obligés
de se découvrir à un moment ou l'autre
ils veulent essayer d'attaquer ou de
faire des menaces
pour l'instant le foot pour l'instant on
n'est pas de bonne case mais
on va voir bon là à 4 c'est un bon coup
l'idée de voir manger et rentrer sur la
colonne avec la tour directement sur un
BK des noirs et ben bon je vais défendre
le pion probablement mais j'aurai des
cases intéressantes
pour les blancs d'ailleurs MP4 même du
A5 direct et sur le long terme ce puit
on va être un problème donc la tête je
fout des deux etc mais plus tard je
mettrai mon fou ici il y aura un
problème sur le plan à 6
donc on peut pas du tout toucher il y a
eu des M6 de jouer donc ok il améliore
il y a un vis-à-vis avec la dame
dans le 4 intéressants ou pas
[Musique]
avec les Noirs
parce que plus on prend et il peut quand
même avoir un peu de danger mais le roi
le roi blanc comme une sale tête
généralement
alors prise prise tour là et du C4 du
coup encore une fois tout à l'heure on
en a parlé l'idée de faire tour à 6
c'est qu'en fait
donc C4 là et quand tu prends avoir
du coup
si tu prends la
[Musique]
ok bon peut-être un faux un faux truc
mais en tout cas c'est compliqué il y a
du calcul
[Musique]
est-ce que tu vas aller voir Saran là du
coup
saine dupliquée que je vous ai faite
franchement vous êtes pas être déçu
voilà c'est là bon par contre les noms
vous savez que je pouvais pas les garder
mais du coup vous avez en haut vous avez
vous avez Jones
contre un petit Sarana c'est vraiment
les meilleurs les meilleurs des deux
équipes là John Sarana salam
[Musique]
il y a pas mal de pièces un peu dans
tous les sens
et vraiment des pièces en prises partout
en fait
un petit peu attaqué il y a un fou
prendre des cartes qui traînent qui
laisserait la tour sans défense en C6
donc bah c'est au blanc et
pas si évident
on peut arriver sur cette position
complètement folle comme ça c'est pas
évident voilà je pense que c'était une
ouh là là
je connais rien du tout mais tu vois que
c'est compliqué
encore une fois il arrive à avoir du jeu
tout le temps
des parties assez marrantes touristes
et du coup je trouve je vais avoir une
question essentielle parce que hier j'ai
bien écouté ton interview de Fab sur le
concept de Benny alors là ce qu'on a une
bonne ou une mauvaise bénédiction
bah là j'ai envie de dire qu'on a plutôt
une bonne mélodie quand même
parce que franchement la benne
généralement on joue pas quoi là on est
actif quoi là on est actif avec les
noirs et franchement c'est plaisant ah
bah j'ai beaucoup les Noirs ici en vrai
après moi la banlie je suis pas je suis
pas contre tu sais de manière générale
ok du coup les blancs décident de
liquide à Max bah ils ont un petit plomb
de plus et s'il arrive à simplifier un
peu ça peut ça peut peut-être pas faire
de mal donc les Noirs ont un forfait en
G7 mais pour l'instant le cavalier
finalement des casse il est solidement
protégé parce que 3 donc
finalement ce plan étroit est quand même
assez important
et ouais si là les prochains échanges
vont vraiment être clé parce que si les
Noirs arrivent à garder des pièces
actives et notamment ce foodcast noir
peut être assez dangereux mais si les
blancs arrivent à bien liquider et à
stabiliser la position probablement
qu'ils auraient une finale un petit peu
supérieure quoi donc je pense que c'est
une bonne benne après la définition
j'étais en train de dupliquer les deux
autres scènes pour tuer tout pour que tu
sois content
d'ailleurs si quelqu'un veut Clipper le
moment de
de la définition d'une bonne et d'une
mauvaise mélonie de hier je peux je peux
vous retrouver la minute
j'ai dû la noter hier quelque part
alors
temps puis on prend ton français 8e
il a bien craqué
bien craqué Sarah
la mange des cadres et la part de la
qualité de moi avec le pion quand même
qui sera passé donc c'est pas encore si
simple mais bon non un petit casque noir
sont ouvertes je pense que je suis trop
D8 fois F3 d'un bouge celui de C5 D5
autour de
800 parce qu'il a pas le choix
il faut qu'il aille défendre ce pion il
a il ajouta
le style de Jump de James Gohan
j'adore son style je suis complètement
à 17h19 la fameuse définition de Fab de
la Benoni donc au bout de à peu près 50
minutes de stream alors vous engager
raisin
[Rires]
5 minutes j'ai pas les j'ai pas le clip
sur le sur le chat et ben on te on te
bande de la chaîne chez ce come fr
5 minutes quelle heure c'était
à 17h20 donc 50 minutes 50 minutes à peu
près merci raisonne
faut pas se prendre la tête
dans ma F6 donc là on va tripler sur la
colonne D voilà en fait on voulait
tripler pour pour forcer le pur avancer
maintenant je pense qu'on va quand même
bloquer le pion une fois alors pour
rêver quand même de voilà pour des six
un moment à chaque fois que le pion est
avance avant c'est un petit peu plus
c'est une souffrance supplémentaire
attention à ça et un peu de jeu quand
même faire un petit peu attention
peut-être dame 7
[Musique]
c'est pas gagnant encore mais enfin il
est mieux quoi mais il faut encore
travailler quoi
ça devrait bien aller parce qu'il pourra
ramener un roi en D6 qui sera le
meilleur bloqueur du pion finalement
la tour c'est pas un très bon bloqueur
parce que comme on peut voir elle avance
en ligne droite donc elle avance contre
le pion elle est bloquée par le pion
alors que un roi enfin idéalement un
cavalier ou un fou arrive à bloquer un
pion et à contrôler pas mal de cases
autour et ici dans le cas précis ce
serait peut-être pour le roi mais dans
ce cas là il faudrait d'abord échanger
les dames
donc cette idée de recette me plaît bien
oui
je prends l'espace tout ça qui a eu un 5
OK
Tam c'est 5 qui joue active
c'est trop faible c'est trop faible
c'est un truc qui sera jamais joué toi
aussi il faut quand même défendre les
pièces
[Musique]
défend en plus
je pense que c'était un précise qu'il a
fait quand même un garçon parce que
maintenant il est un peu en mode je
bouge plus tu vois ça me sert si garder
quand même des trucs parce que je pense
que les Noirs c'est de faire DB6 et
comme ça s'il est blanc arrivent à
pousser des 600 à un moment ils ont plus
fougères pour défendre le pion qui irait
jusqu'à en 17
c'est aussi un coup qui permet aussi de
gaz au roi tu vois donc c'est un coup
assez
flexible qui permet d'améliorer la
position et d'attendre un peu ce qui se
passe quoi
il y a plein de raisons égales il faut
que tu as mentionner qui est très bien
il y a aussi l'espace il y a aussi la
case de fuite il y a plein de choses
est-ce que tu connais vraiment d'autres
parties ou pas
allez c'est parti je vais vous mettre un
petit Paname
avec les Blancs donc dans cette finale
les c'est intéressant parce que les
blancs ils ont leur petit pion fasse se
protéger en A4 qui pourrait en finale de
roi s'avérer très dangereux mais bon
pour l'instant il reste beaucoup de
pièces et les pièces noires semblent un
peu plus actives notamment à la tour en
C2 et j'avais pas vu ça
dans une nouvelle position
[Musique]
F4 qui va gagner mais comme toi tu
parlais tout à l'heure de la fameuse
finale avec le passé est-ce que je te la
donne et je prends la caméra
voilà comme tu l'as dit
dans la position
et on a raté la moitié des choses
mais c'est quand une pièce de moi
il y a pas de même sur fou HK mais mon
cavalier où je veux
[Musique]
plutôt en dessin que j'ai envie de dire
mais ton rêve d'or en live à manger ici
il y a quand même des petits pions en
prison
mais normalement quand même j'ai une
caisse de plus gestion qui va avancer
qui va être fort je vois pas trop trop
trouver un moyen de punir il y a eu j'ai
6 cavalier ici
et bon ok il a mangé j'ai quand même
plus du tout qui permet d'aller manger
un H3 et d'avoir un petit peu de jeu ici
mais
ça a l'air d'aller
tac tac
c'est 5
3 4 5 un pion quand même pour la pièce
donc là il y a les blancs une pièce
d'avance mais c'est vrai que j'ai pas
beaucoup d'espace qu'on a des pièces et
si j'arrive vraiment à changer peut-être
la tour des deux non
du coup cette femme est finale toujours
regarde hop
enfermé
je pense
[Musique]
4 qui va c'est ce qu'il a joué
ça a l'air perdu
on va attendre pour pousser le pion là
je pense jusqu'au bout et il est protégé
donc on va pas précipiter si je l’avance
vite en fait merci à pistrims bon je
crois que raisin
merci on peut le dire au revoir
à bientôt
merci à toi
et en fait non
je peux peut-être des fois faire et le
pion il peut être perdu en fait et du
coup
on va attendre vraiment la fin pour
aller balancer le pion après c'est
cavaliers à deux en plus là j'avais pas
vu mais
en fait c'est abandon est-ce qu'on va
voir une autre du coup
on n'a pas encore vu on n'a pas encore
vu battles
contre laservic
[Musique]
un couteau
trois quatre cinq trois quatre et un
pion de plus qu'un pour les noirs
donc on voit que Salem salaire battu ma
Médoc
sous nos têtes j'ai pas encore la partie
mais donc ça fait 6 3 du coup donc là
pour finir le match il faudrait que
les leviteurs mettent deux et demi sur
trois parties qui restent donc en tout
cas c'est possible qu'on les aie avec
lasavik
déjà Jones qui a l'air de
de battre du coup
[Musique]
Sarana donc a priori ça n'a pas marché
je pense
j'espère que ce sera
[Musique]
vont gagner donc déjà ils vont venir à
trois
gagné mais c'est pas encore terminé
[Musique]
il va très vite c'est très dur
je pense que
impeccable j'ai chèques là voilà j'ai
pris cher
même s'il y a pas grand chose
un petit peu on met le four à 4
attention madame c'est 5 quand même
[Musique]
il y a plus grand chose
que je bouge ma dame d'Amada
il y a plus d'échecs
à une autre partie à une autre alors je
vois James gowen qui c'est la seule qui
qui est encore en lice
donc je te dis ça parce que je vois que
ça marche que les autres il y a le score
déjà en dessous
confirmation donc les avis qu'avec les
noirs qui baignent
et reste cette finale cette finale de
dames et tout ah bah
c'est marrant les blancs mais finalement
il semblerait que le roi noir soit plus
sèche que le roi blanc enfin en tout cas
temporairement
[Musique]
incroyable gros sauvetage de jeux pour
gagner
peut-être dû la prendre je sais pas
Échec roi là et je sais que ça va être
maintenant
face à ça mais trois points ici au
minimum
qui recentre les deux rois qui sont qui
sont chauds
[Musique]
parce que du coup il y a plus la dame
le roi blanc qui se crée sa cachette
petit à petit
oh la tour la tour lâchée mais je peux
encore manger la tienne ah non
qui perd sa partie et qui permet aux
lévitov de finir à 8
incroyable ouais ça aurait pu être
intéressant avec avec du coup un 7,5 ça
revenait un petit peu au score
ça et là du coup avec avec 8 8 4 bah
écoute pour le dernier match il faut
qu'il casse 0 quoi exactement bah là
c'est une remontada très clairement
attends je vais te mettre les câbles
dans la pour la dernière partie pour
qu'on soit bon
alors du coup on a Salem Sarana
du coup
classique le premier contre le premier
le deuxième contre le deuxième etc
donc oui donc on a Salem salé contre
Savannah
[Musique]
plus on va dire
tout ça
ce que j'avais fait c'était bien
du coup la deuxième c'est quoi c'est
John blanc contre
Savannah
[Musique]
je suis d'accord avec toi le tunes dans
tous les cas peu importe l'issue du
match le format est vraiment cool on a
des parties rapides il y a des matchs un
peu dans tous les sens c'est-à-dire
rebondissements c'est ce qu'on aime
alors c'est qui qui joue à 20h c'est une
très bonne question
à 20h aujourd'hui on a les Garden State
spaters contre les spanishmaniak Schrems
donc c'est l'équipe de Samse vient et
burtinic
michera Abi manioc donc le jeune
Américain qui est passé grand maître et
une joueur Bella côté Nashville donc une
autre joueur Georgienne j'imagine et
j'ai déjà espagnol du coup je trouve
connais bien mieux je pense j'ai pas vu
exactement à Paris
je ne connais pas du tout si c'est un
jeune c'est un grand maître qui doit
avoir 18 ans OK et au dernier là le
moins espagnol Karina amarthsumova ah
bah tu sais elle c'est une amie à moi
elle habite
et des fois on va tu vois je la connais
bien
très sympa d'ailleurs qui est très très
copine de Battle
vers 20h alors on le couvrira pas sur la
chaîne mais vous pouvez le voir sur la
chaîne de de cheesecom en anglais
je sais pas s'il y a d'autres langues
qui le couvrent mais en tout cas en
anglais c'est sûr qu'il sera couvert
je propose que pour ce match on regarde
a priori ça les Savana
ça paraît bien même si c'est vrai que
James Medef fera aussi bien plaisir
parce que là elle m'a fait une blague là
c'est bon
j'ai tout j'ai tout bon
très bien
la double caméra
mais un jour on automatisera tout avec
le terminal on arrivera à le changer
t'inquiète pas
mais en fait au final tu vois c'est pas
compliqué mais parce qu'hier j'ai eu un
problème de caméra mais hier c'était un
truc un peu bizarre ce qui m'est arrivé
quoi un truc mais tu es jamais arrivé
chelou mais au final quand ça bug pas et
ben quand même beaucoup plus simple
donc donc voilà donc là on a les parties
qui vont pas tarder à arriver chez moi
sont pas encore là
[Musique]
dans une partie
complètement
se réaliste tiens ce qu'on peut faire
c'est qu'on peut la regarder avec la
avec la barre d'évaluation
pour vous voyez à quel point en fait
c'était chaud
donc ça on a vu tout ça
j'allais j'ai mis l'ordi exprès pour
montrer que j'avais raison mais c'est
pas du tout le coup gentil
ouais c'est quand même
à 0,03
donc ça on a vu ça on a vu à peu près et
au final il a fini par sacrifier la
qualité
pour pour attaquer et franchement ça a
l'air quand même pas mal ce qu'il a fait
semblable quand tu quand tu dis à la fin
que les Blancs ont gagné ça moi tu me
dis que le saharama contre James goin
1-0 j'y crois pas franchement cette
position
et
ok à tout à l'heure gagné
après si la dame j'ai 5 il fallait juste
manger des cinq c'est marrant
faire des échecs etc il vient manger des
sacs
tu as l'impression que OK
bizarrement c'est pas fini c'est pas si
simple à convertir mais ok parce qu'il a
fait c'est pas mal en vrai c'est la
meilleure roi
mais en fait il s'est fait un peu
retourné
[Musique]
en fait c'est que sur bon déjà là j'ai
des maths de partout
[Musique]
mais même ça en fait c'est ouf que il
arrive pas à le finir quoi
c'est un truc de fou qui les défenses
chaque fois
maintenant que le roi est allé à l'autre
bout ça commence à se discuter quoi
bon j'écris ma pion en
[Musique]
h25 avec F4 c'est
dommage après j'ai encore un monsieur
attends mais bon tu vois quelqu'un qui
va arriver là ça avec des matelas ça
peut être compliqué
on l'a vu
moi ça m'intéresse de voir la fin 2020
alors déjà ici
la tour G8
après il fallait faire annuler et là ça
va qui a refusé la nuit
[Musique]
en partant avec sa dame en
il a tenté le matin après il a raison ou
pas raison ça Rama parce que comme il
est quand même pas mal au score
ça pourrait avoir un impact quoi
le genre du coup invisible qui est
extrêmement difficile
alors que d'un point à 5 c'est ça te
échecs
un échec n'importe où je bouge mon roi
contre échec et mat en B2 ah c'est joli
[Musique]
bonne soirée à toi à bientôt
mais c'est pas évident
[Musique]
un roi des quatre meilleurs coups
pour jouer
de bataille et de refaire la guerre quoi
c'est ouf c'est normal d'aller ici mais
la dame de la fin
qui était mieux
avec les Blancs et avec les Noirs contre
n'importe
ce qu'elle a démarré
non toujours pas
ben non je ne sais pas
démarrer j'ai pas encore les games
non ça va pas tarder là ça va être ça va
être la
donc là ça sera dans la partie à moins
qu'il y a un 4-0 si à 4-0
4-0 de
de la part de
norwegnoms
il y aura des partages mais bon
bref ça m'étonnerait que ça fasse ça je
pense que ça va jouer de tous les côtés
l'équipe enfin chez les deux équipes
c'est clairement pas le genre à faire
des petites nulles et c'est c'est
ils vont le solide mais de toute façon
les Noirs c'est vraiment des joueurs de
contre en plus quand tu vois enfin tous
les jours ça allait me saler je solide
il sait pas faire
lui il est solide mais bon Sarah là
c'est la les blancs ça peut être dur
quoi
il est très solide
[Musique]
et la zavit
je vais
juste faire ça
c'est fou ça et j'ai toujours pas à
Paris
[Musique]
qui nous a fait un petit double fiane
chez toi donc avec un fou sur noir sur
la diagonale A8 un fou en G2 face au
fouet finalement donc les blancs sont
sûrement un petit peu mieux d'ailleurs
tu veux garder la barre des vagues
[Musique]
je sais qu'on m'a donné de la laisser je
l'avais pas laissé jusque là mais après
c'est comme tu veux mais l'évaluation
enfin les lignes j'aime bien enlever
aussi mais après la barre on peut la
laisser peut-être
je sais que je prends le chat c'est bien
plus que vous puissiez voir un petit peu
ce qui se passe en temps réel
des fois nous on dit des bêtises aussi
sur l'option dessin donc ça c'est un
petit plan avec cavalier
de voir dans cette position quand même
un truc genre
du coup déjà qu'elle allait prendre des
seins qui a un problème à manger 7
pardon
une vraie question là
aucune dame
[Musique]
non
est-ce qu'il faut forcer un truc avec un
BK
dame 8 mais du coup surprise
ouais bah après c'est peut-être moins
pire que d'avoir un que d'avoir le fou
coincé derrière le pur en dessin c'est
possible
parce que justement dans ces positions
isolées c'est pas forcément
indispensable la période de fou ce qui
est important c'est d'avoir des pièces
actives et bien coordonnées
beaucoup les blancs ici
je donnerais quand même un bel avantage
pour Salem
ici
pour Savannah
il peut pas faire nul sinon
[Musique]
sinon
qui s'est dévoué pour être solide
complètement symétrique bon il y a un
cavalier qui si c'est en dessin que
complètement il y a une certaine volonté
de jouer pour l'égalité
je pense que c'est terminé
enlever ça avant que ça me gêne
donc tour D1 donc là
bon de pression légère parce que du coup
j'ai des colonnes mais c'est vraiment
léger
il y a quand même un jour quand même
attaquer là attaquer le pion 7 faire un
poil attention je pense qu'il faut quand
même précis avec avec les noirs
B4 qu'est-ce qu'on veut jouer en fait
voilà c'est une bonne question parce que
bon cavalier assise pour gagner un temps
sur le pion ça marche pas de ouf soit on
fait à toi et le cavalier joue plus soit
même on fait B5 qui pourrait sécuriser
une Cadence C6 oui j'aime bien l'idée de
faire même la baisse
il peut y avoir des complications à
avoir ça c'est analysé mais dans l'idée
plus tard j'ai regardé qui va être très
fort ici qui va bloquer la colonne qui
va me permettre de rentrer en dehors en
dessin et vous voyez que si jamais
j'arrive à faire ça et bah en fait la
Tour Eiffel noir pour même pas en fait
venir prendre la colonne D parce que je
manque à balai donc j'ai toujours des 7
etc donc un point de vue d'un point de
positionnel ça peut être pas mal donc
il veut se passer par là il commence par
quel sS6 pour contrôler la casse cette
fois du coup il en fait il pense que ça
va
juste mais c'est vrai qu'il y a un autre
point c'est que en fait sur sur B5
peut-être qu'on peut faire à 6 que le
cavalier et les blancs
ça tu joues un coup et en fait après je
fais à 6 les gars je comprends
ça marche c'est ce que j'avais pensé me
voir mais en fait peut-être pas
c'est peut-être pas sûr en fait ou alors
peut-être à 7 au lieu de
[Musique]
même l'idée de faire par exemple
touristique avait des boues je tourne là
mais bon c'est clair que même tour c'est
bien parce que comme ça il tourne de 7
était menace donc là du coup avec avec
ça on enlève tout
exactement est-ce qu'on dirait pas avoir
une partie où ça attaque un petit peu
plus allez
du coup attends je veux juste changer ma
scène donc tu vas aller voir quoi on
fait la zavitch
ça peut être sympa
ah oui ok
il est pas là pour faire ami avec son
adversaire il veut directement
soit j'ai marqué là je marque ma méthode
je sais pas ce que j'ai
pas la même carrure
ok donc c'est simple il m'a dit qu'il
allait prendre un 6e
pas du tout enfin pas du tout c'est un
grand mot mais
est-ce qu'il y a pas un cavalier
français 4 fois 6 ou un truc comme ça
difficile de défendre le cavalier et la
tour
[Musique]
il est mieux et qui gagne que Jones mais
la pression et qui gagne
il nous reste qu'un
en fait Samuel et barbelés mais un peu
comme quand tu joues ta fille dort là tu
avances les pions petit à petit à l'elda
mais enfin justement tu peux essayer de
gagner quoi
si tu reprends pas
attends
ça peut faire peur
enlever la dame parce que le X 6 il
venait après une fois qu'il y avait tout
reprend C4
c'est un peu tactique non non parler de
ça
il faut être précis mais j'ai des cinq
en fait
c'est pas si simple
[Musique]
c'est clairement pas simple du coup je
comprends qu'il est peut-être pas jouer
du coup même ça tu vois enfin j'ai quand
même des pions quoi je peux même bouffer
là
ok il a fait maintenant
alors du coup est-ce que c'est la même
sans la fourchette
et ça gagne la pièce non
[Musique]
plus
il y a plus du tout
donc ça se trouve sur un coup comme
fois-ci si je vous cavalez prendre des 6
et il s'en fout quoi
[Musique]
n'a jamais su quoi
qui est intéressant ça attaque là c'est
des fois là
qui bouge et quand tu bouges je prends
là quoi
peut-être avec peut-être qu'il prendra
avec la tour d'abord pour vraiment tout
liquide et pas avoir de problème de
cloche d'ailleurs
ça a l'air dur là
je pense qu'il faut le changer
échanger pour reprendre mais après
est-ce que vraiment il a emprise ce
cavalier encore un enfant
à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
en fin de partie quand il y a des pions
un peu tous les côtés
est-ce que tu veux qu'on aille voir un
petit peu le féminine costaud
[Musique]
ouais bon égalité matérielle les blancs
en roi un petit peu plus safe mais d'un
autre côté les Noirs il faut qu'ils
mettent la pression et qu'ils essayent
de progresser donc ça peut avoir du sens
d'amener d'amener l'horreur il va pas se
faire mater pour l'instant mais il peut
se révé là un petit peu exploser quand
même bien bien exposé là
après tu vois c'est pas si facile
d'attaquer parce que tu fais quoi tu
fais tour des cinq le roi il peut
repartir en C6 et il y a plus d'échec
tout de suite non mais je te recettes
mais on est d'accord
[Musique]
encore une fois on veut aucune variante
qui mène à la nul quoi sinon l'équipe
perd donc pas évident de pousser les
pions dans des bonnes conditions sans
qu'il traîne quoi non c'est clair c'est
clair là on vous rappelle que le score
c'est 8 4 pour
pour le vitov et du coup les gnomes
doivent mettre 4 0 pour pouvoir arriver
des partages et du coup
avec les noirs
le plus
d'ailleurs je crois que c'est Fatou qui
va m'accompagner demain il me semble si
j'ai bien entendu donc le programme
c'est demain on a tout fait Fatou et
vendredi a priori on a tout fait et
Robinson
problème
des streamers
avec lui
plein de trucs dans le passé
on avait fait une fois aussi
que des meilleurs
il y a pas juste pour des 5 tours
[Musique]
mais vraiment poussé
de faire quelque chose si ce n'est de
d'aller croquer ce pionef et des blancs
et c'est de le pousser quoi
elle a mangé ici ah oui elle a rien quoi
elle laisse même pas le fou
prends je garde mon fou ici quoi et je
continue la pousser ici
c'est juste perdu ça
pour arnaquer les blancs
après on sait jamais
en B3 et vite arrivé j'ai envie de dire
quand
c'est ce qui se passe
et il faudra juste voir ce qui se passe
après s'en fout c'est 6 mais je pense
que j'arrive quand même bien avant sur
roi là
ici
en fait
[Musique]
ancienne championne du monde
alors
encore une fois
que tu changes les caméras ou et les
noms je vais en profiter pour refaire un
petit appel à nos amis qui nous
regardent sur Youtube
merci de regarder sur youtube et je vous
invite à vous abonner à la chaîne parce
que seulement 29% de nos viewers sont
abonnés donc faites partie de ces 29%
pour arriver vers les 30%. puis les bras
et peut-être qu'un jour on passera les
31% donc n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à
la chaîne donc à la chaîne chaise comme
fr sur Youtube mais aussi à la chaîne
Chase 24 fr et suivez-nous sur twitch
suivez-nous partout quoi mais sur
Youtube c'est notamment d'autant plus
intéressant étant donné que nous posons
de temps à autre des vidéos et vous
serez au courant des vidéos et vous
serez également au courant du programme
de stream via des notifications par
YouTube et si jamais cela vous embête un
peu vous pouvez toujours les désactiver
plus tard
donc abonnez-vous abonnez-vous
ça vous coûte rien et ça nous soutient
le slogan le slogan de la
exactement
le soir avant de m'endormir je le répète
10 fois pour que ça rentre bien dans ma
tête
une bonne prière
voilà c'est nul non je croisais 7
faut faire un petit peu attention mais
normalement ça devrait être nul non
c'est pas si parce que j'ai même du G5
tout le temps en fait
sur ça je fais ça
OK
c'est malin
tac on revient mais après souvent on va
on va changer lui contre lui et on va
pousser de lui pour lui il va manger lui
moi j'irai manger lui et à la fin on a
pu en H en miroir là-haut je sais pas si
vous voyez ce que je veux dire
j'aurais changé lui contre lui pour
avoir lui contre lui et les pions
ensemble et en fait on va pousser le
pion F je pense qu'il faut manger voilà
après ce prix F5 voilà et voilà et
pendant qu'il va manger lui je vais me
rends là-haut et c'est fini c'est ce que
je voulais dire tout à l'heure
qui suit les conseils de stouffe et qui
assure donc la victoire c'est ça pour
son équipe
bizarre de
donc ça fait nul du coup ça
ça clou le débat dans ce match donc on
va aller voir l'autre partie on va le
voir un petit peu sur ma méthode contre
Jones
[Musique]
en anglais le cavalier était tabou
il a bien compris ça en tout cas il l'a
donné le cavalier il a pas dépendu
mais comment je passe maintenant est-ce
que je peux mettre ma tour ici genre
tour là tour là et passer par là
on peut aussi pas mal de choses en tout
cas là il essaie d'activer un petit peu
son bras dans un premier temps et ouais
je te manque après on peut essayer
d'activer la Tour
Eiffel
vous voyez mais c'est pas si simple
parce qu'il y avait pas de tour des vies
de tour des deux mais après la tour est
très passive quoi
une petite ressource parce que les Noirs
je vais très vite 3 C4 mais ils auraient
plus se tromper je leur quête se prendre
un tour des 4 maintenant
[Musique]
exactement bah du coup là au lieu de roi
C4 un petit peu avant la roue avec
ça tourne mal de toute façon
quand on est foutu il faut tenter tout
ce qu'on peut exactement
[Musique]
on a la partie de costume qui se
terminait aussi avec un gain du coup de
de
costenio qui et du coup dans la dernière
partie les joueurs qui sont partis en
fait tout le monde est parti j'ai plus
j'ai plus les caméras les gars ils nous
ont abandonné donc je vais mettre une
vue il y a pas des caméras il y a que
nous donc on n'a pas vu la partie de de
pranave près neuf qui a gagné
[Musique]
pour les noirs
et en fait la grosse poireuse 4 la
Grosse Pointe framboise
et qui fait la fourchette je lis
tactique franchement ils sont là ils
sont là les jeunes
ils sont là
du coup c'est le début de la fin
l'ouragan qui est très faible à cause de
l'absence depuis un F
et bon après c'est toujours
ça gigote quoi ça gigote
plus c'est facile du coup
mais il faut un 8 il bouge plus
quand même
au final et quand même trop de problèmes
puis à la fin il y a une petite
ça je pense qu'il l'attendait
cette taxe on va vous la montrer
avec tout reprendre des 5 et ben j'ai je
récupère la tour et je gagne la partie
bon en tout cas on allait un peu vite
mais bon c'est une finale de tour qui
était entre gagnants et nul pour les
noirs et toute façon et ben ça ça
mettait
le match qui se termine de finir par 10
et demi à 5,5 pour l'élevés Wizard c'est
quand même un gros score maintenant
plutôt fleuve il y a quasiment deux fois
plus de points quoi c'est c'est un gros
gros score alors que sur le papier bon
j'aurais moi j'aurais quand même donné
j'aurais quand même donné
les Wizards favoris
et
[Musique]
mais bon tu vois Salem il peut être
chaud
John s'il peut être très chaud prana RIP
chaud enfin tu vois c'est vraiment une
équipe qui est très dangereuse mais
aussi qu'elle est russes sont dangereux
aussi donc voilà donc du coup demain on
aura deux matchs les gars à suivre le
premier à 16h30 le match de de Blitz
donc tu peux nous comprendre tu peux le
mettre maintenant avant qu'on coupe donc
demain on a le match donc de l'équipe
Bleach donc l'équipe coaché par Blitz
stream alors je peux vous donner
probablement les compositions
mvl Catherine Alano et Alexandre Macron
donc le fils d'Étienne donc très très
gros équipe face au Shanghai Tiger mené
par wavey au premier donc c'est un c'est
un jeune joueur chinois bon un petit peu
moins jeune maintenant mais qui s'était
fait connaître il y a quelques années
parce qu'il y a de 16 ans il était passé
2700 et
il avait parti il avait gagné quelques
parties exceptionnelles
et
je crois que c'était ma mère si je me
trompe pas à 15 ans ou 16 ans
nulle part boom 15 ans et sorti du monde
de monstre donc intéressant
puis après les des joueurs des joueurs
et joueuses un petit peu moins connus
enfin il y a Juventus qui est très connu
donc une des meilleures
grands maîtres donc en féminin
qui est classé à peu près 25 50
avec Laurent quand j'ai commenté
les outils
mais il est prononcé
je crois ok bref peu importe contre
Louis yping donc c'est des bons joueurs
mais je pense que c'est pas non plus des
grosses terreurs
donc je pense pas que ce soit bon ils
sont quand même favoris au dernier ça
c'est clair mais après quand même devant
bah on a on a un demi-tour en plus on a
quand tu arrives à la nouille qui va
faire nos taf je pense que Blitz
favorise sur le papier mais après
après chaud après il faut jouer
c'est pas clair donc ça c'est le premier
match à 16h30 donc il sera commenté sur
la chaîne de Blitz stream et à 19h on
enchaîne directement avec le match des
saintes
emmené par Fabiano Caruana au premier
échiquier j'ai suivi par quelques
auteurs Nicolas Théodore que je ne
connais pas c'est un Grec qui a 2006 qui
est c'est un jeune qui est chaud ok
après vin rouge Jeanne à Kobe
[Musique]
Arméno américain j'imagine
qui donne sous le cas où on peut trouver
pas mal de Master Class de lui sur
YouTube sur la chaîne du sandwich club
et Rochelle
c'est inconnu pour moi inconnu
j'ai envie de te dire mais
2300 et l'eau comme la féminine donc
c'est une belle équipe aussi
et en face on a ben on a les Indiens
avec irigazi en tête d'affiche avec
tabac Tabeille en deuxième la féminine
avec harika c'est chaud et encore un
grand maître indien à 2500 hello Adita
mital donc c'est c'est vraiment un gros
match
moi demain je mettrais un petit
un petit avantage pour la team mgd1 qui
est les
Indiens face au Saint Louis
après on va voir mais encore une fois un
match mais en fait
on a notre petite réponse donc
apparemment zoom se prononce chou
ah ok donc ce serait chouïe
ok ok ça marche bon en tout cas ben
écoute merci à toi pour me rendre compte
stream Nathan
merci à tous sur le chat d'avoir été
présent et de accompagner pendant
ce passionnant match de proches League
donc demain encore une fois 16h30 chez
blitzrim et 19h sur tous comme FR pour
la prochaine
journée des de la project voilà voilà
le mot de la fin c'est bah encore une
fois demain on aura que des beaux matchs
abonnez-vous à notre chaîne YouTube
est-ce que tu peux dire la petite
en fait je crois que je vais trop nommer
j'ai pas de boule que le feu je vais
mettre monsieur Youtube je crois
je vais te le lien de YouTube sur ton
nom
en tout cas merci à tous et puis à
demain ciao ciao bonne